ما تراه هو آفات جدري القرد
على ساقي ذراع آدم البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا
حتى عينه أسفل
رمش العين بجوار مقلة العين
في الأسبوع السابق ذهب إلى
مهرجان وبعد عودته
تلقى بريدًا إلكترونيًا من
منظمي المهرجان يقول  شخص ما
كان مصابًا بجدري القرد ، كان آخر تعرض
يمكنني التفكير فيه في الثالث من يوليو
، ثم بحلول الحادي عشر ، عندما
لاحظت العلامات على ذراعي لأول مرة ،
وهذا أمر مهم يُطلق عليه
فترة الحضانة ، وهي الفترة بين
التعرض لأول مرة.  يمكن أن تظهر الأعراض في
أي مكان من ستة أيام إلى ما
يصل إلى 21 يومًا في هذه الفاشية ، ثم بحلول
اليوم الثاني عشر ،
يكون هناك حمى ممتلئة ، لذلك في غضون ثلاثة
أيام من الإصابة بهذه الحمى ،
استمر آدم في الظهور في الطفح الجلدي حتى
في مؤخرة حلقه  وكانت تلك
هي الأسوأ في الأيام التي لم يستطع آدم تناول الطعام فيها
أو حتى التحدث عن الشيء الوحيد الذي بدا
أنه يساعد في الغرغرة بمحلول الليدوكائين
، هل سبق لك أن واجهت أي شيء
كهذا ،
كنت سأفعل نوعًا ما
مثل هذا إلى تهجين بين
بكتيريا بكتيريا الحلق أحادية اللون بالإضافة
إلى الجدري
الدكتور ستايسي لين هو مؤسس
المركز الصحي للتوعية في
بيتسبرغ ، وهو مركز يركز على صحة المثليين
، وهي أيضًا طبيبة آدم لديه
آفة في داخل جفنه  ولكن
إذا تمزق
ذلك ، فسوف يقوم بتلقيح عينه تلقائيًا
تبين أن حوالي 25 في المائة من الأشخاص
المصابين بجدري القرود يصابون
بآفات حول أعينهم وإذا
انتشرت العدوى إلى القرنية ، فقد
يتسبب ذلك في العمى وهذا ما
دفعني إلى علاجه.  يوجد
علاج لجدري القردة ، إنه
مضاد للفيروسات يُعرف باسم teapox ، تمت
الموافقة عليه منذ عام 2018 في الولايات
المتحدة لعلاج الجدري ، وهو فيروس من
نفس عائلة جدري القردة ،
وقد أظهرت الدراسات الحديثة الآن فعاليتها
ضد جدري القردة وكذلك ما هو  أنت
ترى من حيث الاستجابة لهذا
الدواء
بصراحة ،
لقد كان
عميقاً أن تشاهد التقدم من خلال
الصور
وتذوب حرفياً
أوا  أود أن أقول ثلاث
جرعات ،
لكن هذه المشكلة تم تشخيص ما لا يقل عن 4900
شخص رسميًا بمرض
جدري القردة ، واعتبارًا من 22 يوليو ،
يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أن أكثر من 230 مريضًا
قد عولجوا بالفعل
بالأدوية ، ما هو مستوى
الوعي بمرض الجدري  نعم ، أعتقد أنه أمر
ضئيل للغاية ، هذا مرض
يؤثر بشكل غير متناسب على
مجتمع المثليين وأعتقد أنه حتى
يشق طريقه حقًا إلى
عالم الجنس الآخر
، من المحتمل أن تكون
قصة مرض الجدري من عدة نواحٍ
رائعة.
في الماضي ، بدافع القلق من إمكانية تحويل الجدري في
يوم من الأيام إلى سلاح ، خزنت الحكومة الفيدرالية
ما لا يقل عن 1.7
مليون جرعة ،
ولكن الآن حتى في منتصف هذا التفشي الجديد ، كان
الحصول على هذه الجرعات لمن هم
بحاجة إليها يمثل تحديًا حقيقيًا
تتحدث عنه خمسة
ستة
ساق النهار لإيصال هذا الدواء إليك
في مكتب الطبيب المحلي
والأوراق وكل البيروقراطية
لتحقيق ذلك مرهقة للغاية
تستغرق بضع ساعات من الوقت
وقتك وهذا هو الحاجز الذي ربما يكون
هناك الكثير من الناس الذين قد
يشاهدون هذا الآن يقولون لذلك هذا
الطبيب يقول أن هذه الآفات تذوب
وأنا جالس هنا أعاني ولا يمكنني
الحصول عليها فهذه مشكلة بالتأكيد
هناك  الكثير من الفوارق الصحية في
مجتمع المثليين
، لا يقفز اللاعبون الرئيسيون
لعلاج مرض يصيب الرجال المثليين في المقام الأول ،
حتى هذه المقابلة وافق آدم على
التحدث معي ، لكنه طلب منا استخدام
اسمه الأول فقط وإبقاء وجهه مخفيًا.
وصمة العار حقيقية ومن المؤلم
أنها تربطها بكونها
مرض رجل مثلي الجنس أو مرض الرجل المخنثين
والذي أعتقد أنه
ليس
طريقة رائعة للتعامل معها لأن أي
مرض يمكن أن يكون مرضًا لأي شخص
الأسبوع الماضي ، قام مركز
السيطرة على الأمراض بتبسيط عملية الموافقة على الجدري  تقليل
كمية الأعمال الورقية ومتطلبات المتابعة
يقول الدكتور لين إن ذلك يساعد ولكنه
لا يزال غير كافٍ إذا لم
يتم تعريف هذا أو على الأقل وصفه بأنه
مرض رجل مثلي الجنس ثنائي الجنس هل أنت  ضع علامة على أن
بعض هذه الحواجز التي تتحدث عنها
لن تكون موجودة أو لن
تكون كبيرة على
الأرجح ،
أعني أنني أود أن أعتقد أن
رهاب المثلية الجنسية لم يعد موجودًا أو أن
العنصرية في الطب غير موجودة  بعد الآن ،
لكن أعتقد أن لدينا الكثير من الأدلة
لنقول إن
عيادة لين في بيتسبرغ تشهد هذا
العدد الكبير من المرضى الذين يعانون من
آفات في العين ، وقد تمكنت من الحصول على موافقة
من السلطات الصحية الفيدرالية والمحلية
للحفاظ على الجرعات في متناول اليد في
مكاتبهم.  هي ثمينة ،
يتم الاحتفاظ بها في مكان مغلق والمفتاح أمر
ذو قيمة ، لذا احتفظ بها بالطبع في مكان
آمن ،
ما مدى السرعة التي تعتقد أنها أحدثت
تأثيرًا خلال اليومين الأولين ،
أشعر حقًا بأنني اليوم أفضل كثيرًا لأنني
وصفت لأول مرة
جدري على بلدي.  من ناحية كان الأمر بهذه الضخامة ونوعًا
من الألم ولكن في غضون
اليومين الأولين من تناول مضادات الفيروسات
انخفض حجمه تمامًا وبحلول
اليوم الثالث تم تحجيمه تمامًا